all right so I want to welcome you guys
to NDC second day it's fantastic
competing with a lot of really great
talks but I think every speaker in every
track can say that so I really want to
thank you for coming to this talk like I
said we're gonna be talking about
building scalable and maintainable apps
using typescript and react so my name is
Camryn I work at Target downtown on the
side in addition to my full-time job I
do some Pluralsight courses I have one
on Raven dB one of the sponsors here at
NDC I also contribute to a game engine
called Excalibur jeaious it's written in
typescript that's sort of where I got
started writing typescript and I also
have an application called keep track of
my games which is a game organization
app it also lets you track upcoming
releases sends you notifications and
that's served as the inspiration for
this talk which I'll get into at home I
have a wife and son and dog but she's
black and white not brown and white on
the on the side there in the picture my
wife and I spent six months in Europe on
a sabbatical and we visited Morocco so
that's a monkey from Morocco I also
enjoyed doing tabletop RPGs board games
some video games programming on the side
as you can probably tell listening to
audio books and I own two guitars that I
don't play so those are my hobbies you
can see that gaming sort of runs through
the line of stuff that I do and that's
one of my passions so why am I here
today and why are you guys listening to
this talk so I just want to sort of go
over my motivations for this talk what
do I want to achieve when I'm writing
and working on my applications so one of
my goals is to make my apps easier to
maintain and one of my goals is to make
them easier to scale but what does that
actually mean
I want to make sure that we set the
baseline for what I'm going to be
talking about so when we are talking
about scalable code are we talking about
something like this where you want to
support 99 levels of navigations
therefore you create 99 jQuery selectors
this by the way actual production code
that we found in one of our code bases I
mean how else would you support 99
levels of navigation right because
recursion is not a thing and CSS
selectors don't support nesting so we
are not talking about this kind of
scalable what we're talking about is
making our code easier to extend and by
that I mean adding new features usually
you hear this term MVP we're working on
an MVP right so our Minimum Viable
Product but then we want to add features
down the road so how do we plan for that
and make sure that our code base can
scale we also want to make it easy to
collaborate on I work on a team of five
other developers at work and we want to
make sure that we all have work to do we
don't conflict with each other we're
working in the same code base and we
also want to make it easy to reuse code
and update code that also means for
maintainability we want it to be easy to
refactor and this is where typescript
comes into play we also want to make it
easier to understand and by that I mean
coming into a new code base as I'm sure
we all have come into new code bases
just try to measure the time how long
does it take you to like fully grok an
entire code base and usually it's like
six months until you've like fully
understand everything that's involved
what typescript allows us to do is
describe the stuff in our application a
little bit more precisely so it's easier
to get on board it and you'll see what I
mean when I talk about typescript
we also want it to be easier to test we
write tests we aim for about 85% code
coverage not that that really matters
what we want to do is we want to write
tests that are valuable not just write
tests for the sake of writing tests and
typescript allows us to write more
robust tests because they are also type
checked so that's what I mean when I say
scalable maintainable typescript if you
are new to typescript and you're not
familiar with it it is a compile to
JavaScript language it's transpiled it
offers static type checking this is one
of its most powerful abilities that's
why it's called type type script if
you're coming from c-sharp or java then
you're probably used to static type
but if you're coming just from pure
javascript javascript is a dynamically
typed language not a statically typed
language but typescript sort of brings
the best of both of those worlds where
you can mix both dynamic typing and
static typing it has really really good
editor tooling and I'm on my laptop and
so I'm going to be showing you all these
code snippets in the context of visual
studio code which is the editor that I
use and you're gonna see what I mean
when I say fantastic tooling it also
helps you provide more refactor friendly
code because the typescript compiler is
understanding your code base as you
write it that also means that it can
find all your references it can keep
track of where things are in the
codebase and so you can usually hit a
hotkey to let go to where things are
defined or find all the references to
something when I came into my current
team at Target we're just doing a pure
JavaScript code base and the way that
people find references in a pure
JavaScript code base is by doing command
F across the file system right so you
don't do that with typescript it knows
where everything is react is a component
based presentation library I wouldn't
call it a framework it has a very small
surface area the API is pretty small you
basically have components and then those
components can have some methods on them
but it allows you to compose your app as
small reusable units of components so
react has a more functional mindset than
say angular where you're creating
components and decorating them with es6
decorators and stuff like that
so react is what I like to say is just a
little bit closer to the metal appear a
pure JavaScript fan you're probably
going to be a bigger fan of react and
you would be of angular but they both
have pros and cons the reason that I
chose react for my application was that
it has really good performance because
it's based on the virtual Dom it's able
to have a representation of your DOM and
it's able to detect differences so it
doesn't have to rely on the browser
api's which are a lot slower so it has
very fast performance
so this is a code sample of using
typescript with react I have these cool
buttons right here if I click on them
they're going to bring me into Visual
Studio code into the file so this is an
example of using react here I have a
functional component a stateless
functional component and really it's not
that different from just regular
JavaScript this is just a function using
arrow syntax and it has a single
property called props and it's rendering
and h1 text and this is JSX so if you're
not familiar with this syntax this is
like HTML and JavaScript well you can
also see that I have this funky syntax
here this is from typescript
so this syntax is a what's called a type
annotation and what it is is it's
describing what these props are and the
way that you can read this is similar to
how you would read regular JavaScript
syntax this is an object that has a text
property and that text property is a
type string here's another example of an
es6 class component this has an even
funkier syntax here called generic
generic syntax so the way that you can
read this these two generic parameters
one the first one represents props the
second one represents the state of my
component so the way that I would read
this is I would say class app extends
react component of empty props because
it's an empty object and state props
that have a hello property that are type
string and you can even see here that
I'm initializing my state to hello
camera so what is the benefit of this
well with typescript if I for example
change this to a boolean suddenly I'm
going to get some red squiggly lines and
the squiggly lines are gonna yell at me
and they're gonna say type boolean is
not assignable to type string so this is
one of the primary benefits that you get
with static type checking it's saying
that I can't convert a boolean to a
string that's not what you told me it is
however if you go ahead and change that
to boolean then suddenly you're okay but
if you check check out down here I'm
referencing my other state list
component
I have my text prop and I'm trying to
pass in the current value for this dot
state dot hello
well this dot state hello as you can
sort of see here at the very bottom is
of type boolean well boolean and text
boolean and string don't jibe together
so typescript is also gonna throw an
error here because I'm using this
component wrong so one of the reasons
that I chose to use react or static type
checking with react is that I get full
type checking all the way down into the
JSX
which i think is really powerful so
let's undo that there fantastic now the
inspiration for this talk came from an
application that I run it's
non-commercial it's totally free it's
called keep tracking my games what it
allows you to do like I said is sort of
organize your game collection but
initially I'd created it to track
upcoming games and so context around
this this was built in net so
historically have been a.net developer
and it's also a hybrid app which means
that it has server-side rendered pages
and then inside of those pages there are
pieces of JavaScript that enhance it
that make it more like a single page app
experience and originally I had written
this in jQuery and knockout j/s so what
I've been doing over the past year is
migrating that to typescript and react
and that sort of served as the genesis
for this talk so a lot of the patterns
that I'm going to talk about have come
experience from that as well as projects
that I work on at work where we do
typescript redux and react
I chose react because it's a heavily
interactive UI so this is an example of
sorting your game collection and this is
the react version so I'm using some
fancy animations but you can see that
people can pick whether whether or not
they want to prioritize certain games in
their backlog but then when they switch
it to a different sort then the icons
change and a lot of props and rendering
changes so I was running into
performance issues with this because
this is supposed to support thousands of
games in your game collection and react
is allowing me to do this type of thing
and that's that's live right so react is
super powerful for that
this talk is based on a true story and
what I mean by that is that I'm going to
show you patterns and practices that
I've come to think are useful and we've
implemented a lot of them on the
projects that I'm on but I'm also
showing you ideal pattern state so my
entire code base isn't necessarily
migrated to all these patterns yet but I
think they're going to be useful so the
concepts that I will mention include the
Redux store so if you've used redux
before that is a state container for
your application it allows you to manage
global State and that is supposed to be
your single source of truth for your
application and it can be pretty heavy
for a small application but if you're
working on a big production app where
you have to support lots of people
across the world like at my project it's
really useful because you can ship that
state and debug logs and stuff like that
to be able to reproduce people's airs if
they run into any state is the data
representing your app at a point in time
one of the benefits of Redux is that
because it's tracking state over time
you can go back in time you can step
through your state changes and it's
keeping track of all of that actions in
redux are just a fancy word for a JSON
object with a type property and that
type property can be anything in my
examples they're going to be strings but
with a certain twist with typescript to
make them strongly-typed
action creators is just another fancy
word for a function that returns an
action that's all it does so it takes
some parameters then it outputs a plain
old JSON object the reason that we have
action creators is so that we are
consistently creating actions across our
codebase and reducers are another term
that was really confusing at first but
what they do is they take those actions
and then they return a new updated state
based on those actions so let's say that
I want to fetch a game from my server
which is one of the examples we'll see
it will take that game response from the
server and it will shove it into the
Redux State and that's a new mutation of
the state therefore it's a new
representation of our state great so
what we're going to talk about today
we're going to
take a look at some patterns about
folder layout and structure State and
reducers in terms of redux actions and
redux action creators and redux and
finally we're going to talk about plain
old react components and how to manage
their state so for folder layout this is
a common layout that you'll see if
you're starting out learning react which
is the generic folder layout and by that
I mean that there are generic folders
like actions components reducers
selectors which are just ways to get
information from state and just regular
generic services well this works okay
for a small application but the issue
with this is that files are going to be
spread out the components folder isn't
gonna scale very well because these
folders are start to get gonna start to
get pretty deep and if your app starts
to grow there's gonna be a lot more
folders in addition like I said it's
fine for a small site but what we really
need is something that scales a little
bit better and this layout is inspired
by Ryan Florence and he proposed this
way to organize a react application by
screens so you can sort of see here that
we have a screens folder inside of our
screens folder we have an app folder
that represents our shell for the
application and all we're doing is we're
just having a convention where each
screen folder can have a components
folder which is your components that are
used in that screen and then we have a
shared folder which is going to be a
little special this is a way to share
components between that screen and any
sub screens in your app so what this
allows us to do is achieve a scalable
nesting layout so let's jump into the
code base quick here so here is my
screens folder my components folder for
my app I have sub screens so my app is
my shell now I want to maybe show a game
details screen
well that's its own screen down here or
maybe I want to show the list organize
screen and that has its own components
that are being used there in my shared
app state or a shared app folder I have
like an icon that I might want to share
across my applique
and icons probably good a good thing to
share across your app so how do I
actually reference those share
components this achieves better
collaboration co-locating related files
closer importance I'll go over those
again this is how you would normally
refer to a shared component you'd use
this dot dot slash dot slash well we're
just we're talking about scalable
nesting right so I can have lots of
different sub screens this dot dot slash
is gonna be repeated a whole lot of
times as soon as you get two three four
five levels deep that's that's not cool
so what we're gonna do is we're going to
do a cool thing and we're going to fix
typescript to actually resolve modules
using a convention where we just say
shared slash and what that's going to do
is going to emulate how node resolves
modules and that it looks in the current
directory and then just keeps going one
directory up and tries to match that
module name so you can see that because
I'm using typescript and I've configured
it correctly it is finding the exact
location for that module which means
what I can do is I can hit f12 and I can
just go to the definition of that module
there's no hunting and pecking around
trying to figure out where these modules
are it's able to resolve that how
exactly does that work through this
magic right here in our TS config JSON
so there's two properties base URL and
paths and what I'm doing here is I'm
sitting up aliases so I'm saying
anything that starts with tilde slash
you're just gonna map it to the source
directory anything after that with the
star is gonna be substituted in addition
I'm also gonna do shared slash star and
you can see that I've mapped screens app
shared anything after that is going to
be mapped there now you might be
pointing out or thinking to yourself
that this is neat but what isn't so
great is that I have to define all these
shared folders statically there is an
open issue for this in the typescript
repository they're hopefully going to
address it but honestly as soon as you
start adding screens you're probably
going to
initial batch of screens and then as you
work on your application over time this
file is not going to change that much I
don't find it to be a huge deal if you
really want to go the extra mile what
you can do I have a code sample right
here you could take that TS config and
you can mutate it and you could go ahead
and search for all the shared folders
and just add them to that paths property
and then generate a new TS config and
you could add this to your web pack
config or you could add it to your npm
scripts i'm not going to show that but
this is the code sample that that does
that alright so what do we achieve by
doing this folder layout we have a
scalable folder structure we have
shorter import paths we have shared
component resolution and it supports the
typescript go to definition
functionality and even you saw in vs
code it was able to support vs code
what's not so great of course is that
you are currently forced to provide
shared paths ok redux State this is
interesting because when you start out
using typescript and redux what I had
initially done is I had tried to
describe my entire redux state as one
single typescript interface an interface
is just a description or a contract for
the shape of an object so what I was
doing is I was just saying here's my
entire application state and here's one
file that has it and it didn't really
scale very well what I'm going to show
you right now is something that we can
just call bottom-up state so
bottom-up meaning it goes from the
farthest screen down and then bubbles up
to a final exposure of our state in a
single type property so how does that
work this is the root of our state we
have our source / state that's the
indexed es that we're in right now and
all I'm doing here is I'm importing our
app state that's our first screen
remember it's our shell so app is going
to have its own state and what we're
just going to do is we're going to
port that state and we're gonna expose
it and what we're going to use is this
keyword here called type of and what
does that do so what type of does is it
actually in typescript just gets the
definition of that type and exposes it
as its own type that's a little bit meta
so what it does is it's actually just
describing what that shape is going to
look like when it's finally done so that
we don't have to declare it upfront so
I'm going to use go to definition I'm
going to find out what does this state
look like so this is our app state I
have a game property on it that's from
my sub screen game you could imagine
here that I have multiple sub screens
like my list organized page my list edit
page my list create page they're all
going to have their own state and I'm
going to export them right here
let's go farther down so now we've
reached the bottom and the bottom
actually is the one that has the
interface so this is my game screen
state and my game screen state has a
details property that details property
has an ID that's a number you can also
have a game that could be null or an
object and I would actually have an
actual class here this was a real
application but then I'm defining my
initial state and I'm just saying that
it's going to match this shape why do I
do that
why couldn't I just do this and just
export this well if I do that let's say
that I add a new property what's gonna
happen is that type scripts gonna be
okay this is just a lint err type
scripts gonna be okay with this but
that's not what I want what I want to do
is I want to enforce that this object
matches my game state and now I'll get a
typescript err and when you scroll all
the way down says object literal can
only specify own properties and I don't
know about foo you didn't tell me about
foo
who is not up here therefore there's an
error so that's gonna help us make sure
that our state is consistent throughout
the application we're not passing extra
properties that we don't know about
and just went through this
that's bottom up state what about
reducers can we do the same thing with
reducers yes we can so we're gonna do
bottom-up reducers this is let me just
close these these are the this is the
root reducer this is the final reducer
that gets created gets put into our
store I'm going to hit f12 on here this
is my a producer this should look a
little familiar I'm using the combined
reducers function from redux but I'm
also passing an extra parameter here
what's that for so the generic syntax
right here for state what I'm doing is
I'm just passing in that exported type
from earlier state so as a reminder
that's what I'm putting as what my
reducers should look like so then I'm
importing my game reducer that's from my
sub screen so I'm gonna go to my game
reducer and I'm gonna do the same thing
I'm just gonna combine reducers from all
the parts of my state that are part of
my game screen in this case details and
we're just gonna go to the short version
of details and this should also look
familiar because this is what you would
typically do in a Redux application for
a reducer you would just have a function
that takes some state i'm fault i'm just
sending it to our initial state what's
initial state initial state is that
constant that i created that I exported
so that's our initial state and then I'm
taking an action and for now action can
be anything but we're gonna fix that
next so now I've created bottom-up
reducers so I don't have to define what
my reducers all are going to look like I
don't have to import them all at the
root of my project they're all defined
in their screens and they're exported
and then they just sort of get composed
together so what is that bias we
maximize type inference from typescript
so what I mean
by that as I'm saying I'm not describing
my entire state up front I'm allowing it
to be composed from all my sub screens
that's bottom up composable state so
screens manage their own state they're
encapsulated so each screen has its own
representation of state and then it just
gets exported and then I just consume it
and using that shared folder you can
imagine that I could actually just
create shared state so in my shared
folder if I created a stores folder I
could potentially create multiple Redux
stores if I want to and they could be
shared between screens or sub screens
okay what about actions reducers handle
actions we need a way to represent those
actions in a way that we can make sure
they stay consistent so this is what my
actions look like we have load game that
should be familiar and Redux usually
actions are constant strings so we have
my load game is one of my actions that I
have and then I have this interface this
typescript interface that describes what
that action has it has an ID it has a
game object and it's extending this
thing called action but I'll get into
that next why is it's significant that
I'm exporting a Const load game besides
being a typical thing that you would do
in a JavaScript app is if it doesn't
change your be Const but Const has a
connotation in typescript
what it will do is it will give it the
type of the literal string that you're
giving it so the type of this load game
variable this constant is the literal
string game slash load okay what do I
mean by that if I change this to a var
then the type of load game is a string
so typescript doesn't understand that
it's a very specific string because it's
a variable it could be you could assign
a different string to this so it's not a
literal type but because I'm using
constant the literal type of this is
game load and you'll see the
significance of that in a second
now this helper that I've created is
really simple so pay attention to this
code right here all I'm doing is I'm
describing an interface a typescript
interface that takes a generic argument
the type of my action and I'm just by
default I'm setting it to string generic
defaults are really cool and I wish
c-sharp had them but in typescript you
can set the default of a generic
argument and I'm setting it to string so
it really could be anything any type of
string but what I'm doing here is I'm
saying I'm using that special type of
operator again where I'm saying I'm
creating an action of this literal
string right here game load and that is
going to be substituted in this type
property so actions all have a type
property that was one of the things that
Redux enforces and now I'm describing
that type and my load game action has ID
and game all right so what does that get
us exactly well this is back to my
reducer now my reducer has a little bit
more code we still have our initial
state that stayed the same and what I
showed you but now rather than typing
action as any we're typing it as this
thing called game action so remember
that I'm in my game screen my game
screen is going to have several
different types of actions how can I
tell typescript that my actions could be
one or more of these these actions these
types of actions so I can do that using
something called a type Union and
typescript this is just saying game
action can be load game action or save
game action so it can be 1 or 1 or
either of these and as you can imagine I
could add more so I just use the pipe
operator separate other types of actions
that this could be okay that's
interesting but why do I need to do that
why should I do that well remember that
we typed action action type in our
helper and we substituted that literal
constant value as what the type property
should be
well if I hover over this you can see
the typescript has inferred that the two
types that it could be is game load and
game safe this is what's called a
discriminated union this is significant
because what this means is that I can
take advantage of type scripts type
guard functionality where I can say hey
when I handle the load game action type
then I'm gonna get intellisense and type
checking for everything on that specific
action type so game and ID are both
properties of our load game action but
if I come back down here and I've
created another action I didn't show you
called save game save game does not have
a game property if I go here and I hit
f12 we can see that save game only has
an ID number so it only has one property
it does not have a game property so type
script is checking for us and making
sure that I'm referencing the right
properties so now I can do save game I
can return my ID back so that's pretty
cool I think this is like one of the
most powerful features and one of the
best things I like about using
typescript with react doing this sort of
discriminated union is really powerful
because it makes sure that my actions
are going to be consistent and if I
update my actions my reducers are gonna
throw compiler errors so I can make sure
I fixed them before I get too far if you
don't want to do a switch statement you
could do something called an action map
this is another way in redux to do
handling for reducers instead of
defining a switch statement what you can
do is just define a dictionary so what
this dictionary looks like is something
like this I'm creating in actions
constant and it's a JavaScript JSON
object and the keys of that JSON object
are my constants so I'm just using
computed properties syntax there and
then I'm referencing these individual
smaller functions down below so if you
don't want to have a big switch
statement full of stuff you can do it
this way and the way that I'm typing
this is very similar I still have my
type game app option our game action and
I still have my type of initial state
details but what I've done here is I'm
just using a type alias just to shorten
that up
so type aliases are super nice you can
just shorten long type names up so now
this is just state so I can say I have
my reducer actions that are have my type
state game action and what's cool about
this is that I can change this to be for
example save game action and I still get
the same type checking so game does not
exist on type action so this is another
way to do it
what do these helpers look like again
this is getting into more crazier
typescript syntax but the premise is
still simple so I'm creating an
interface this is my contract for my
object and I'm using this syntax right
here these square brackets mean this is
an object that I can index into and that
property key is of type string and the
value of that key the value of that
property is going to be a function that
takes state in action and returns state
this definition right here is the Redux
convention for reducers right so I take
my state I take my action and I just
return the new representation of state
now what we can do is we can just create
a helper function that just sort of
takes care of that boilerplate of
checking to make sure that my action is
handled I handled my action if it's
available otherwise I just returned my
regular state and this is all type
checked if you don't like this larger
syntax or this more this more verbose
syntax what you could do is you could do
a more compact syntax right here so this
is the same exact thing but now instead
of breaking these out into
for it functions where I have to create
a separate actions map and all that what
I can just do is just do it all here in
line so that's even a shorter way to do
it and this is still all type checked if
I hover over state you can see that
state is what I expected to be has my ID
my game because that's my details state
and that's coming from right here type
of initial state details so that's an
even shorter way to do that okay so
review what did we just do we created
strongly typed actions so if our actions
change across our code base then our
reducers can update they throw errors
and if our state changes actions will
also throw errors so we're making sure
that it's just consistent across the
codebase therefore when other members of
our team are working on actions are
working on state if they update it and I
update it and we make sure that we're
all in sync reducer action handlers are
typed so they're statically typed and
they're checked so my reducers make sure
that we're handling the right actions
I'm looking for the right properties on
my actions we also have reusable type
utilities now that we can use and if
actions or state change reducers break
action creators these are those little
functions that return new actions so
let's take a look at what those look
like so what I've done here is I've
created a function called load game and
it's using this helper that I've made
called action creator what is that what
is that bi'ness and what does that look
like well this is their typical action
creator if you're learning Redux
you'll see this pattern a lot you just
exporting a function
I just prefixed it with underscore to
not conflict with this one and I'm
taking my payload what is a payload
actions have a type property but then
they can have any number of other
properties that's represents what's on
your action and I'm just saying that
that's what a payload is called it's
everything but the type property and
I've created another helper for that
called action payload but
regardless I'm just spreading those
properties over in my action so you
passed me whatever you want and I'm
going to make sure that I passed the
right type for my action so how can we
get that to play nice with typescript so
we have our action payload type here
this is a type alias and we're saying t
action extends actually here's my action
up here I'm just saying that whatever
you pass me as a generic argument has to
be related to an action has to be like
extended from action which means that it
must have a type property well if I
would just want to take all the
properties except type how could I
describe that in typescript and I'm
using a utility called home it this is
not built into typescript but I got it
from a really simple nice little blog
post that sort of had some other nice
type script type helpers but what this
does is that you give it your type that
you want and then you give it a list of
properties you want to emit so if I
wanted to I could say emit type emit
game or emit ID and so I'm gonna get an
object back in typescript so the
compiler understands that I'm returning
an object without these properties on it
you could also do pick pick is the
opposite of emit and pick is built in
typescript but this is the opposite this
is just give me these properties but I
don't want to do that I just want to
take all the properties except type
that's what omit lets us do what about
this action creator function this looks
a little bit funky we are doing the same
thing
so we're saying create an action creator
for this action and I'm gonna pass it
the type the constant the type that I
want to pass in and all this is doing is
it's just doing the same thing that I
was doing before it's taking this little
boilerplate and genera sizing it so
here's my function that takes my payload
I am casting it as object because if I
didn't do that
petracles going to complain because
payload has that type property
so it's getting confused I'm just gonna
tell typescript no worries bud treated
as just a regular plain object
spread the properties and then pass in
the type that I'm giving that type type
type type and force it to be a tea
action it's just telling typescript
whatever word gets returned from this
function is a tea action so now I can do
this I can just use this little action
creator utility and I get all the
strongly typed benefits of this so now I
don't have to have I don't have to have
this code anymore and get rid of it and
now load game load game the definition
of low game is a function that takes
payload guess what it even tells me what
properties are gonna be their ID and
game and it's gonna return a load game
action load game action is right there
has an ID and it came it's all
statically typed fantastic now we need
to dispatch an action let me show what
that looks like so I've created a
function down here this is not like a
redux action what this is doing I'm
using a library called redux thunk it's
like the simplest way to sort of take
promises for actions and I'm using async
in a wait what I'm doing is I'm just
creating a function that returns another
function and that function has a
dispatch so dispatch is part of redux
it's a way that you send actions out for
people to know about so I'm being passed
a dispatch handler right here I'm just
going to xkcd I'm grabbing some JSON I'm
awaiting for it and then I call dispatch
and dispatch you can see it here that
I'm not I'm not doing anything
typescript e right here there's no
there's no typescript really in any of
this I am typing it right here this is a
built-in type declaration that's part of
redux but it's all still strongly typed
so I have my load game I have my
dispatch and once the fetch result is
done
I am dispatching my action so I can
mutate my state
what does that look like in a component
well here I have an example of a game
details component I'm doing the same
thing where it is dispatch coming from
I'm just using connect so connect should
look familiar if you're using Redux and
react I'm just connecting it by by
connecting it I'm getting that dispatch
function again and I'm just doing the
same thing I'm calling dispatch with
fetch game so that's all I need to do
there's no extra stuff I have to do with
typescript because I've already done the
hard work of making sure that my action
is strongly typed and redux thunk comes
with its own type definition that
handles these promises so let me hover
over that again you can see here that we
have an async action this is coming from
redux thunk this is my game state and
then it's returning a promise which
means what I can do is this is all just
strongly typed because it's a promise
you then result and then whatever I want
to do console.log result and this is all
strongly typed so that's pretty cool so
like I just showed it's all typed safe
with intellisense so again what did that
by us we have some utilities now that we
can get rid of some of this boilerplate
for creating actions dispatch is
strongly typed I don't have to do
anything extra with typescript
to just get it to work because I've done
all the heavy lifting and my actions
dispatches all just passing the types
through so it's all about trying to
maximize or minimize the number of like
type annotations that I have to have
around my code and we also ensure that
actions are invoked with the correct
arguments I should sort of show this but
if I try to pass in something else type
so it's going to throw an error right
because fetch game is a function that
only has a single argument called ID
which is a type number so now if people
if someone goes ahead if another team
member goes ahead and changes this
action that's why we have an action
creator that's going to type scripts
gonna understand that any reference to
this function needs to be updated
a compiler one thing that's not so great
about this is that you have to expose
dispatch on props so u s-- may be sort
of caught that I wasn't using something
like bind action creators or map
dispatch to props that's because you've
got to do like more boilerplate type
script stuff and it's a lot easier just
to expose dispatch so you could be evil
and you could just do a global dispatch
and I wouldn't fault you for it because
it would be easier to mock if you're
using jest you just do jest up mock
store and you just pass in your dispatch
mock so that's another option finally
the last set of patterns props and state
just for regular components this if you
have used typescript with react this
shouldn't be a surprise this is just the
most basic stuff that you could do with
typescript and react so remember that I
mentioned before that we have these
types from react pure component so when
you do regular JavaScript without
typescript you're still going to do this
you're gonna do classic stands react up
pure component typescript adds these
extra definitions these generic
arguments so the first one like I said
before is props the second one estate
these are just two interfaces that make
sure that our stuff is strongly typed by
doing this we get the type checking for
JSX we get the type checking inside of
our state all cool stateless is even
simpler you got your function it takes
props your props are these that's it
there's nothing extra that you have to
do for that where it gets interesting is
and more complex patterns this is the
render props pattern let's go into this
the render props pattern if you haven't
used it before what it does is we define
a prop on our component and the
convention typically is to use children
children is a built in property that
gets sent to all react components that's
what's inside the tags the JSX tags
whatever is inside inside there gets
assigned it to children and what we're
doing is we're just
typing that explicitly as a function so
the render prop pattern what you do here
is you take your JSX tag and then inside
of it you use the JavaScript escape
syntax the curly braces and we say props
dot children I'm going to call you I'm
gonna invoke you because you're a
function and I can just pass you some
new props because presumably this
component is a little bit more involved
in just this this is my game image
component right there game image
component it might take some you know
different URLs for box art for a game
and depending on screen resolution my
return you know a different sized image
what I want to do is I want to
encapsulate that and anything inside of
it just gets passed with the raw name
the image URL is so we can just do alt
source title so then we can just render
our image so that's an example of the
render prop pattern but what I don't
want to do is I don't want to just do
this all over the place so it'd be kind
of nice if I could clean that up a
little and we can all we all we really
have to do is just pull it into type
alias so type alias is like I said are
awesome for just shortening stuff that
you're going to be typing all the time
so rather than having to put this
function type definition all over the
place now I've just created a render
prop generic type that just takes
whatever props you want to pass down so
render props are what's going to be
passed to the children so that's a nice
pattern to do for that what about
connecting your components to redux
there's a little bit more involved and
this is something this is an approach
that i found works pretty well and it
tries to minimize the amount of like
boilerplate type annotations that you
got to do remember that like taking
typescript into your application is not
like a small chore and it's also
something that your whole team has to
agree with as you can probably see it's
not gonna be the simplest thing in the
world but you get a lot of really great
benefits especially if your teams can
scale so when I'm saying like trying to
minimize the amount of type annotations
I just want to take advantage of
typescript inference as much as possible
so that my team doesn't have to update
spend time updating type annotations all
of it all over the place so in this case
we still have our props I've just
renamed it to own props own props if you
haven't heard the term before is really
just the properties on my component that
do not come from Redux State props are
what I'm calling props that I get from
redux
where are those coming from those are
coming from Mapp state two props this is
something you've probably seen in just
regular normal vanilla redux this is the
first argument that you can pass to
connect map state to props takes in your
state optionally it can take in some own
props and then it returns state props so
all I'm doing here I'm just hard-coding
this I'm returning my image name and
selected image name and selected is part
of my state props definition but I'm
also passing these own props that are
coming so this component specifically is
the game list item and this is something
I actually do in my app because people
can reorder games like that's not coming
from redux because if you're in the
middle of a drag operation it's not
updating state we need to pass that in
as an own prop so how can we tell
typescript that we expect all of this
stuff when we finally get down to game
list item how can we tell typescript
that all these properties should be
available to us so again I'm using the
type alias and you can maybe see where
this is going and creating a type alias
of all these three things I am using
something called a type intersection so
this is different than the type Union a
union is or so they can be this type or
this type and does what it says it
combines the definitions of multiple
types together and it does it from left
to right so I'm saying take own props
add stuff from state props also add a
dispatch prop and dispatch prop is
coming from there we react Redux type
definitions but again I don't want to
type this all the time so what I'm going
to do is I'm just going to like take
this dispatch
and separate redux state props and I'm
gonna pull it into a utility and we're
going to call it sr c sr c stands for
stateless react component that's what we
want to call it and in regular react you
can do react dot SFC i don't know if you
use that before sorry let's actually get
some type check in react
SFC react at the SFC is just a type
alias for react out stateless component
so you don't have to type in stateless
component all the time so in our case we
don't want to type in you know stateless
Redux component all the time where you
can just type in SRC what SRC does is it
encapsulate that little type alias that
i had before so we are taking our state
props in our own props and guess what
because we can set defaults we can also
just make it optional maybe it doesn't
take own props maybe there's just props
from redux
in this case we do have some own props
so I'm gonna head it back in okay that's
cool what does that look like man
there's a lot of stuff on here on the
first one we have something called Redux
props Redux props are just our regular
type alias that you saw before this guy
own props state props required blah blah
blah what we're doing here is we're just
being able to set a default and then
we're just doing that same type
intersection so this T state props
generic parameters you can just give
them a name if you want to this could
just be T foo and then we have we have a
type error but again with the power of
type script I can just call this T foo
renames it so we have t foods or which
are our state props own props cetera so
that's just that's just a shorter way to
do that and then we encapsulate the
react out stateless component and you're
gonna make fun of me because what I
should have done is I should have done
SFC right so now we have stateless
functional component and the props that
we're going to pass it are our redux
props and what cool thing about that is
that we can then re
is that also for es6 classes so this is
extending reactor component that's just
the default react component and again
the first generic parameter is my props
so it's a type redux props and then
t-state and you can see that i'm just
setting these all to default objects so
that at the bare minimum I can just say
extends Redux component without passing
in any extra generic parameters
fantastic so what did that bias we have
a way now to model splitting that own
props and state props so now they can be
separate interfaces I've shown you how
to substitute those inside of your own
type utilities we can reduce a lot of
like excessive type intersections to get
that dispatch on to our props we've
created some reusable type utilities now
we can use throughout the codebase so
other team members can take advantage of
them I also showed you how to do render
prop pattern typing so that you have a
consistent way to describe render props
and you can go down the rabbit hole for
that one if you have different types of
render props that you want to do so
altogether now if you have been
following along you may have seen that
there is a github repository with all
these patterns so all this code that I'm
showing you right now is all available
for you to play with peruse submit PRS
tell me I'm wrong that kind of thing
fantastic I just want to say before I
end that there's always room for
improvement this I've given this
presentation this is a third time and I
totally revamped it for NDC because
there were so many new patterns that
I've been learning and there's always
room for improvement and I'm sure some
of you in this room who have used touch
scripting react might have your own
patterns and I want to know about them
so open up an issue on the repo or send
me an email or tweet at me
send me your some of your patterns I'm
super interested I'm still learning
react I'm fairly new myself so I hope
if you have been using reactor you knew
to react and you want to try to use
typescript I've given you some patterns
and practices to help you create a
little bit more maintainable reusable
code so with that thanks for listening
we have some time for questions if there
are any before I finally end yes sir yes
there it is any other questions yeah
[Music]
sure so your question was about the
bottom-up state and how is that
maintained between like if I'm using
react router or something like that so
if we go to the very root of my state so
all we're doing we're still doing all
the normal stuff that you would do with
Redux where we're just creating our
default state so that's going to be our
full object that describes our
application and this is just using
imports to compose all of our sub
screens together so at the end of the
day you're still going to have final
state in fact we have a little bit of
time what I'm gonna do we have like a
minute or two I'm just gonna start this
application there shouldn't be any
errors and we're going to have a little
that's fine
let me just undo these so I'm using
create react app for the sample I don't
have the dev tools on here I don't have
the dev tools open but what you would
see is you would just see the whole
entire application state composed as one
so you could use this if you want to
with like code splitting for web pack
so maybe each of your screens are
probably going to be routes right and so
then when you you can do dynamic imports
to compose your state together and so
you could still do type checking and all
that if you do dynamic imports does that
help
cool any other questions
otherwise let's get back to the final
slide thanks for listening you can
follow me on Twitter or find me online
at hamurana kiss comm if all this
typescript stuff kind of went over your
head I have an eight hour course that is
gonna take you from zero to hero so in
that in that course we actually migrated
three different JavaScript code bases to
typescript and I go through all the
stuff that I just talked about in more
detail if you're interested there is a
Midwest jazz version of this talk that
goes into some more performance type
stuff but that was so much that was so
much content that it just needs to be a
whole separate talk but with that thank
you all so much
have it have a great rest of your
conference
[Applause]